[Music]
the up-and-down career of an actor isn't
always fun but once you land a role in a
popular show like Shadowhunters it can
be incredibly rewarding wait until you
hear which Shadowhunters actor had 80
projects under their belt before landing
a major TV series role don't forget to
subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's check
out the cast of Shadowhunters before
they were famous
Alicia Wainwright you might know the
gorgeous Alicia as the werewolf that is
Maya Roberts Alicia was born on July
14th 1989 in Florida although she got
her acting breakthrough for her role in
shadow hunters she also had several
roles in some other shows you might have
or might not have heard of before do you
remember a cartoon called Disney star
darlings the show is all about twelve
fairy-like characters called starlings
that used to grant wishes for the
earthlings until an evil force
threatened starl and the starlings were
then sent to the earth to save the day
and they were introduced as star
darlings
Alicia also appeared in a TV series
called switched at birth as well as the
popular YouTube duo smosh's TV series
but although she had quite a few minor
roles in other series she's best known
for portraying Maya her role in shadow
hunters also landed her a role in the TV
series lethal weapons and a TV movie The
Wedding do-over we just can't wait to
see her catapulted into the acting world
even though her werewolf character is
absolutely iconic and will never be able
to get replaced we're sure Alicia will
be fabulous in every acting world she
will get Harry Shum Jr Harry Shue might
play a warlock in shadow hunters for the
truth is you've seen him in plenty of
movies before and an even bigger truth
is that Harry can actually move Harry is
a really talented dancer whose career
started back in 2004 when he appeared in
you got sir we've all learned thee we're
all in this together dance but have you
ever paid attention to the dancers Cary
was never in the main movies but he is
in the we're all in this together
tutorial look out for the dude in the
white shirt he also had a minor role in
Zoey 101 and was featured in plenty of
other series and do he remember the
step-up series he was featured in both
step up - and step up three as cable the
video editor that's known for his sick
freestyle of course you might also know
him as Mike Chang from the hit series
Glee the truth is Harry has had a pretty
busy career but it seems like he's not
stopping anytime soon Isaiah Mustafa now
we're talking Isaiah Mustafa might be
known as Luke Garroway the werewolf -
some of you but the truth is his acting
career is very interesting before he got
famous Isaiah was actually an NFL
practice squad wide receiver you might
also recognize him as the Old Spice dude
from the the man your man could smell
like Old Spice commercials Isiah had two
very minor roles in NCIS and NCIS Los
Angeles Isiah actually played a
policeman in two episodes of the real
Days of Our Lives version he's also had
several roles where his able to show off
his comedic timing and deliver a
performance that was just as fantastic
as his portrayal of Luke he even played
detective ray Goodson in the TV series
of Charlie's Angels you might even
remember him as Moe's hip executive from
the Three Stooges his acting career
really took off after his role as
officer Wilkins in Horrible Bosses
but he became really memorable in
Shadowhunters we have a feeling this
show will open even more career doors
for Isaiah and we can't wait to see it
all happen in murad Tobia Arad Tobia aka
Isabelle Lightwood as an interesting
acting history that's unlike anyone
elses on this cast and we absolutely
love her for it Emma rods background and
acting isn't as rich as some of the
others we've talked about today but
that's because she was actually a model
she got massively recognized once people
started noticing her in shadow hunters
if anything this proves that all you
need is talent and Emeraude definitely
is talented on top of being completely
gorgeous one of the first role she
landed was actually pretty big she was
cast as Elizabeth on a Nickelodeon
latin-american show she then landed a
role in a popular venezuelan telenovela
before having her first main character
role as Esmeralda and tattooed love
seriously she's a perfect telenovela
actress but
really glad her talent allowed her to
snatch some of the big rolls while her
role as Isabel might be the role she's
most known for tattooed love shows a
Murad's fantastic acting skills as of
April 2018 it doesn't seem like Emeraude
has any other roles booked apart from
Shadowhunters but we're pretty sure that
fact will change in just a few months
Mathew daddario now here's another
gorgeous actor whose face we always like
to see on screen Mathew frequently makes
everyone sneeze shake when he appears on
the show as the strict and serious Alec
Lightwood you have to admit that this
man is absolutely divine to look at but
despite the fact that Matthew is
wonderful at portraying Alec this role
was the first major while he got he's
absolutely talented but it seems like he
wasn't able to catch a break until
Shadowhunters unlike the other actors on
this show
Matthew was only cast in nine roles
before this but they were all very minor
and while his cast mates were mainly a
part of various TV series Matthew was
only featured in movies you might
recognize him as Channing from delivery
man or Aaron in breathe in but to be
completely honest we can't wait to see
what will happen to Matthews career
after Shadowhunters he deserves to be
cast in a show like Riverdale which will
for sure make his career take off on a
new level
he might be known as the Hawkeye from
Shadowhunters we have a feeling he
deserves much much more
Alberto Rosen day the insanely talented
Alberto rezende is absolutely wonderful
as Simon the vampire his acting resume
is actually even shorter than Matthew's
before his Shadowhunters Fame Alberto
only appeared in two TV series and two
short movies if you're a Lawton order
fan you may have seen him in the special
victim unit series where he played
Jordan Messina but apart from these
minor episodes Alberto actually hasn't
been exposed to the acting world before
he became instantly famous with
Shadowhunters but it seems like acting
isn't the only future for Alberto he's
also been credited as the executive
producer for a short movie called my
American identity project which shows
interviews with people talking about
what they believe is their America
identity as of April two thousand
eighteen Alberto doesn't seem to have
any other acting projects book but we're
sure that will change soon we'd love to
see him play a vampire in another show
or perhaps he could show off his comedic
timing in a movie or a sitcom
Dominic sure would Dominic sure would is
the only British actor from the people
we're talking about today the talented
actor has had several interesting roles
but it was his role as Jace Wayland that
catapulted him into a well-known actor
did you know he was actually Taylor
Swiss boyfriend in her style music video
re watch it and see if you can spot
Dominic he also had a major role in one
of the episodes of Modern Family as well
as several other mini TV series and
while his Jace Wayland character might
be against demons his character in
Vampire Academy was in fact a vampire he
showed off he can play both parts much
like some of the other cast members we
don't know much about Dominic's life
before Fame but we can't get over the
fact that he was in Taylor Swift music
video
he definitely has that James Dean
daydream look in his eyes Dominic might
not have a huge acting resume as of yet
but this is one of our favourite facts
ever Katherine McNamara now if there's
anyone that has had a long acting career
it's Katherine McNamara she definitely
deserves to be the star of the show
because by the looks of it it was a long
road to get there before she became
famous Katherine had several minor
uncredited roles in various TV series
just like Alberto she also appeared in
the Special Victims Unit version of Law
& Order however her episode was featured
five years before Alberto's she also had
an uncredited role on 30 rock and even
appeared on a Glee episode as a bun head
you could also find her in Jessie
kicking it and even CSI seriously we'd
be here all day if we talked about all
this series and movies Katherine's been
in but despite her keeping busy her
acting talent got massively recognized
after she appeared on Shadowhunters as
the stubborn Clary Fairchild Katherine's
acting career is a living proof that
things take time but you have to be
patient and just keep on doing what you
love good things always come to those
who wait and look at her now playing a
lead role in one of the most awesome TV
series ever what an inspiration David
Castro
David aka the slightly arrogant Rafael
Santiago also didn't catch any major
movie or TV breaks until Shadowhunters
but his life before Fame might actually
be different from the others were
mentioning today because David booked
his first gig at the age of five how
cool is that it turns out Harry isn't
the only dancer on this show we really
need Shadowhunters the musical at some
point it would be amazing
later on he ended up getting a lead role
in the remake of the little fugitive he
then got some minor roles in movies like
a range and 27 dresses before landing
the role of Frankie in the are we there
yet TV series but Shadowhunters was the
role where David was truly able to show
off his acting chops and it seemed that
people started to notice he got one of
the lead roles in a movie announced in
2018 called stronger than pretty and we
bet this won't be the only one alan
vents praying but now let's talk about
the man that's one of the most
recognizable actors out of the people
we've talked about today Alan Van spring
I'll invent Springs Fame definitely
didn't start with the Shadowhunters Alan
has been credited for 80 roles so far in
his lifetime and to make things even
better most of his roles were TV series
just like his fellow castmates he had
several side character roles before
landing the role of Howlin in earth
final conflict just two years after and
several TV roles in between he landed
the spot on Paradise Falls as Johnny
Bruce if there's a person that works
hard when it comes to booking TV series
roles
it's definitely Alan he was even
featured in one of college humors
episodes
it seems very fitting that this
established TV series actor actually got
the role of the extremely charismatic
Valentin Morgenstern we can't wait to
see what's in store for Alan and we have
a feeling he'll be cast in some major
movies - the road to fame might be long
but if there's one thing we learn from
the cast of Shadowhunters is that it
definitely pays off no matter how many
minor character roles you have to play
beforehand and that's all for our video
let us
you think in the comments thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]